c'est le grand rendez-vous de
l'aéronautique mondiale le salon du
bourget a ouvert ses portes aujourd'hui
aux visiteurs après avoir été réservé
pendant quatre jours aux professionnels
alors pour ceux qui aiment les avions
c'est l'occasion de se faire plaisir
mais vous allez voir que ces journées
portes ouvertes sont aussi
potentiellement un danger pour les
constructeurs
parmi les badauds se cachent aussi des
espions regardez cette enquête édifiante
elle est signée fabien shadow et jean
francois monier au salon du bourget on
regarde d'abord ce qui se passe en l'air
un ciel si très haute surveillance
c'est pourtant plus bas dans les allées
du salon qu'il faut être le plus
attentif ici les tentatives d'espionnage
industriel se font au grand jour
frédéric berthet y est policier
spécialisé dans le renseignement
intérieur il traque les visiteurs un peu
trop curieux il a repéré cet homme en
blanc qui tourne autour de ces réacteurs
entraînant des gens qui reviennent
souvent sur l'instant de reprendre
on est dans le cas où l'on pourrait
avoir affaire à quelqu'un on semble
parler d'espionnage mais quelqu'un qui
recherche certaines informations sur le
produit est parti de techniques se
fondre dans la masse
paraître un visiteur another
pourquoi prend t-il autant de photos
tourre s'y prête
nous allons lui poser la question qu'est
ce qu'on fait comme photo
chez les photomatons
personnel vous a expliqué une réponse
beaucoup trop vague pour lever le doute
on n'a pas pu vérifier les informations
qui vous avez vous pris puisque son but
je n'étais pas content
un visiteur qui part avec un secret
c'est arrivé lors du dernier salon il y
a deux ans en fait la condition toujours
au rayon et laon différents joueurs et
là bas sont en fait crac
le joueur dont sous les ongles se
trouvant des particules de ce joueur qui
seront analysées pour savoir de quoi est
fait ce joint cet exemple est devenue un
cas d'école enseigner aux exposants pour
les inciter à la prudence
autre danger les données numériques ce
policier bien vérifié pendant le salon
que ce sous-traitant respectent bien les
consignes on sait qu'il ya des règles
jamais laissé son pc dans la voiture
toujours l'avoir avec soi dans une
mallette
il faut être prudent quoi retrait de
l'air plutôt grande prudence car avec
l'informatique quelques minutes
d'inattention peuvent suffire pour tous
se faire voler sur internet on peut
trouver rapidement le sur certains sites
des petits logiciels qui une fois qu'ils
sont installés sur
une clé usb peuvent tromper rapidement
certaines données sur un ordinateur
portable depuis quatre ans près de 250
attaques ont été recensées dans le seul
secteur de l'aéronautique est revu sans
être découvert c'est tout le paradoxe du
salon du bourget la plus grande vitrine
aéronautique du monde qui doit savoir
garder ses secrets